CRISIS, CHINA CONTINUES TO
THREATEN THE REST OF US WITH WET
MARKETS.
RIGHT NOW, THE UNITED STATES IS
BY FAR THE WORLD’S TOP FUNDER OF
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
WE GIVE THEM ABOUT $58 MILLION
EVERY YEAR.
THAT’S DOUBLE WHAT ANY OTHER
COUNTRY DONATES FOR SOME REASON,
BUT FOR THE ORGANIZATION’S
LEADERS, THERE’S ONLY ONE
COUNTRY THAT MATTERS, AND IS NOT
US.
IT’S CHINA.
RIGHT NOW, TAIWAN IS BATTLING
CORONAVIRUS, BUT THEY ARE DENIED
MEMBERSHIP IN THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
THEY CAN’T EVEN HAVE OBSERVER
STATUS HERE TO WHY IS THAT?
PEOPLE ARE DYING BUT THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION REFUSES TO
PROTECT THEM.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
BECAUSE CHINA OBJECTS TO ANYONE
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT TAIWAN IS A
NATION.
FROM THE BEGINNING, WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION OFFICIALS HAVE
PRAISED CHINA’S RESPONSE TO
CORONAVIRUS.
THEY REPEATED THE COUNTRIES LIES
AS FACTS TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
INITIALLY, TRYING TO CLAIM THE
CORONAVIRUS COULD NOT BE
TRANSMITTED FROM PERSON TO
PERSON EVEN THOUGH DOCTORS IN
WUHAN KNEW OTHERWISE.
AND IT WAS OBVIOUSLY UNTRUE.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
TOLD THAT LIED TO THE WORLD AND
THAT HINDERED GLOBAL PREPARATION
TO CONTAIN THE VIRUS.
THEY MADE IT WORSE, NOT BETTER.
AN ON THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION PRAISED CHINA FOR
ITS TRANSPARENCY, A CRUEL JOKE,
AS THOSE LIVES HAD BEEN EXPOSED,
THEIR SUBSERVIENCE TO THEIR
MASTERS IN BEIJING HAS ONLY
BECOME MORE OBVIOUS.
ON SATURDAY, A HONG KONG
TELEVISION STATION AIRED AN
INTERVIEW WITH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION DIRECTOR.
WE WANT TO SHOW YOU THIS WHOLE
THING.
WE HOPE YOU WATCH CAREFULLY
BECAUSE IT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING
ABOUT WHERE THIS WORLD IS GOING
AND WHY YOU SHOULD BE REALLY
NERVOUS ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT OF
CHINA.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE W.H.O. CONSIDERS
HONG KONG MEMBERSHIP?
HELLO?
>> SORRY, I COULDN’T HEAR YOUR
QUESTION.
>> LET ME REPEAT THE QUESTION.
>> THAT’S OKAY, LET’S MOVE TO
ANOTHER ONE THEN.
>> I’M ACTUALLY CURIOUS, TALKING
ABOUT TAIWAN AS WELL, TAIWAN
CASE.
>> WE DECIDED TO GIVE HIM
ANOTHER CALL TO FOLLOW UP.
>> I JUST WANTED TO SEE IF YOU
COULD COMMENT A BIT ON HOW
TAIWAN HAS DONE SO FAR IN TERMS
OF CONTAINING THE VIRUS.
>> WE’VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT
CHINA.
WHEN YOU LOOK ACROSS ALL THE
DIFFERENT AREAS OF CHINA,
THEY’VE ACTUALLY ALL DONE QUITE
A GOOD JOB.
SO WITH THAT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING US TO
PARTICIPATE AND GOOD LUCK AS YOU
GO FORWARD WITH THE BATTLE IN
HONG KONG.
>> Tucker: IN THE MIDDLE OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC, THEY ARE
REFUSING TO HELP A COUNTRY
BECAUSE CHINA TOLD THEM NOT TO.
AND ON THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WHICH REPRESENTS
ALL OF US IS BOLDLY WITHOUT
SHAME REPEATING THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT PROPAGANDA.
WASN’T JUST CAUGHT IN A BAD
MOMENT OVER SKYPE.
HERE’S ANOTHER CLIP OF HIM
SUCKING UP TO THE GOVERNMENT OF
CHINA.
THE MAP TO THE PEOPLE OF WUHAN,
IT IS RECOGNIZED THE WORLD IS IN
YOUR DEBT AND WHEN THIS DISEASE
FINISHES, HOPEFULLY WE WILL HAVE
A CHANCE TO THINK THE PEOPLE OF
WUHAN FOR THE ROLE THEY PLAYED
IN IT.
>> Tucker: IT IS BEYOND
DISGUSTING.
IT’S SCARY.
GORDON CHANG IS THE AUTHOR OF
"THE COMING COLLAPSE OF CHINA"
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOU’VE BEEN ON THIS TOPIC FOR
SUCH A LONG TIME.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION WHICH NORMAL
PEOPLE NEED TO LOOK AT THEM AND
THINK THEY ARE KEEPING THE WORLD
SAFE FROM PANDEMICS, BUT THEY’RE
ACTUALLY ACTING AS A SPOKESMAN
FOR THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINA.
DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU?
>> THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
SOME TIME, TUCKER.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS THAT WE’VE GOT TO
BE AS CONCERNED ABOUT, SO IT’S
NOT JUST BRUCE, WHO BY THE WAY
HE SAID HE HAD ABSOLUTELY NO
REASON TO QUESTION CHINA’S
NUMBERS.
IT’S ALSO THE DIRECTOR GENERAL.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE NUMBER ONE
GUIDE.
IN LATE JANUARY, HE GAVE AN
INTERVIEW TO CHINA’S STATE MEDIA
SAYING THAT BEIJING’S RESPONSE
WAS ADMIRABLE, SHOULD BE
EMULATED BY THE REST OF THE
WORLD, AND THEN HE SAID IT ALL
SHOWS THE SUPERIORITY OF CHINA’S
SOCIALIST SYSTEM.
CHINA HAS A TOTALITARIAN SYSTEM
AND WHAT HE WAS DOING WAS
ATTACKING DEMOCRACY ON BEHALF OF
BEIJING.
SO THIS IS REALLY DESPICABLE
ACROSS THE BOARD.
>> Tucker: THIS REALLY
MATTERS.
THIS IS UNLIKE NBA PLAYERS
KOWTOWING TO THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
WHERE IS BILL GATES, WHO IS THE
SINGLE LARGEST INDIVIDUAL
FUNDER?
WHY ISN’T HE SAYING ANYTHING?
WHY AREN’T OUR LEADERS SAYING
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS?
>> YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS IS DANGEROUS BECAUSE FOR
THE LAST TEN DAYS OF JANUARY AND
FOR THE FIRST TEN OR 15 DAYS
OF FEBRUARY, THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WAS PARROTING
BEIJING’S LINE THAT NO COUNTRY
SHOULD ENACT TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS
ON CHINA.
AND BECAUSE THEY WERE NOTICED
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS ARE VERY FEW
OF THEM, THE UNITED STATES BEING
AN EXCEPTION, WHAT HAPPENED WAS
THIS VIRUS SPREAD EVEN FARTHER
AROUND CHINA’S BORDERS.
SO WHAT THE W.H.O. HAS DONE WAS
IT ACTUALLY HELPED SPREAD THE
CORONAVIRUS AROUND THE WORLD,
AND IT DID IT ON BEHALF OF
BEIJING.
>> Tucker: IT IS JUST BEYOND
BELIEF.